av i have a job for you
you better gear up for this
of course so in this clip the first
gun we get a good look at is a fairly
conventional looking handgun
it appears to have a polymer frame and
some sort of
slide so far so conventional but um
there is an internal bolt like a broom
handle mouser that pulls back and then
at a certain point a slide then comes
back as well we can see different
controls on the side of the gun there
none of those make immediate sense to me
that might just be um
what we call in the movie industry
greebly's to to dress up the design and
make it look cool
i also noticed that there are what
appear to be very interesting
iron sights on this gun which are
reminiscent of
fiber optic sights on a contemporary
pistol so they're red they're glowing
there's a sort of
triangle in the front and an angle at
the back that's all fine but the modern
trend is very much toward red dot sights
on pistols
i'll be very surprised if by 2077
every handgun doesn't have some sort of
low profile red dot
sight on it but hey this is a sort of
1980s inspired
cyberpunk feature so anything goes
[Music]
okay i've got a pause there as well
right smart the smart weapons
as far as i can gather the smart bit is
the ammunition a little bit like
fifth element where we've got the repeat
function where you shoot one bullet to a
location and then the others
magically follow it
which is very cool but ridiculous we've
got sort of takes on that where the
ammunition is
being guided in some way so that's
something that's got a minor basis in
in reality and might well be where
things go in the future
in some way because we have things like
the tracking point
rifle which was a fairly conventional
rifle but
you you would it was almost like a jet
fighter set up you would mark
where your reticle was you press a
button near the trigger and that
would tell the computer in the gun that
that's what you want to hit
and then you would hold down the trigger
and the gun would fire
when everything was lined up main basis
of that was it was a
laser range finder built into the gun so
it knows the distance
it calculates the bullet drop for the
type of ammunition that's loaded into
the gun
the only thing it couldn't do is to
gauge wind speed
and direction which is uh one of the
many skills that
snipers have to develop the other
approach
is what we're seeing in cyberpunk which
is guiding the projectile
and that's something that on a on a
small arms level so like below 20
millimeter caliber
we've only really seen from darpa in
america
who have experimented with 50 caliber
bullets because you need them you need
the bullet to be big enough to contain
guidance technology and they're able to
effectively
inflate or deflate bands on the bullet
to change the air resistance over the
bullet and steer it so you can actually
fire a bullet roughly where you want it
to go and then guide it into the exact
spot you want it to go
i don't know if the the developers have
been inspired by that or just
or by fifth element or just thought it
would be damn cool if bullets could be
guided to their target
but that's the real world parallel for
what we're seeing here
my um expertise lies in firearms
i'm not really a melee weapon or edged
weapon person
but um i can't resist briefly talking
about the
thermal katana sci-fi edge weapons are
kind of fascinating so the archetypal
version is obviously the lightsaber from
star wars and it looks like this thermal
katana is kind of giving you that
ability now from what i understand of
average weapons
heating the blade isn't going to do a
great deal
in fact what it might do is cauterize
the wound that you inflict
and make it easier for your opponent to
kill you unless this is somehow
surface of the sun hot like lightsaber
hot which i guess it must be
then this isn't going to be any more
effective than a conventional
steel blade
something that's been a staple of um
well first person shooters i know this
is a
role-playing game but it is first person
and it is shooty
as well is the good old double barrel
shotgun
so since since doom two
which is really not advanced technology
in any way
it's it's some of the oldest firearm
technology that's around today
it's got it's got the classic victorian
era lever
on on the top break open design i think
because just
in a game an over an under barrel design
just doesn't look as cool and then
this this version has got all sorts of
gubbins
attached to it um and i have to assume
looking at that
that is some sort of electromagnetic
acceleration there so it looks like
we've got
somewhat conventional 12 gauge
ammunition and then the projectiles are
being accelerated
by magnets but it's still got the
sliding safety catch where we'd expect
to see it on a modern shotgun for
shooting clays or whatever so safety
first even in the
apocalyptic future i guess
[Music]
again speaking of shotguns we've got
a more conventional concept
in the carnage from the amusingly named
budget arms
the the carnage appears to be a
futuristic pump action shotgun which is
curious in a way because we already have
lots of
really good self-loading shotguns
they're reliable enough
that the pump shotgun is kind of as far
as i'm aware falling away in sort of
common use
what this appears to be is a sort of
self-defense
riot shotgun type thing with a with a
futuristic
aesthetic to it strip that away and it's
not much different than something like a
remington 870 as far as i can tell
we've got that futuristic stock with a
sort of thumb hole design
which is not seen as terribly practical
in real life
now it says four gauge buckshot
okay that's big so if you're not aware
the number goes down
as the shot size goes up so 12 gauge is
what we're used to
a four gauge is massive
and it does kind of look quite massive
now that i look at the magazine
tube under the barrel and the actual
muzzle itself
and wouldn't necessarily hold too many
rounds either because it's a big old
cartridge
[Music]
interesting
so that um the the neca mata there uh
it's built as a sniper rifle um and i
suspect in universe that's exactly what
it is looking at how it's being
used it does look like a sort of super
accurate precision
weapon it's got the adjustable but stock
with a cheap piece
suggested or something more like a
sniper rifle equally with this level of
technology and
there's no reason why it couldn't be a
designated marksman rifle as well or
instead a dmr
by swapping those optical sights you
could have
engagement ranges from 300 meters out to
2000 or more that's potentially where
technology will will
go is that weapons will be configurable
keen to see how that plays out in the
game
and we've got some specs on the screen
there or special capabilities on the
screen they're semi-automatic fair
enough
apds armor-piercing discarding sabo
ammunition no reason why that couldn't
be a thing steel though is a bit weird
i'd
i'd expect that the future alternate
near future whatever
would probably have something more dense
harder than steel so we very quickly
flash on some different optics here
which are interesting
and looks like it might use several
small cameras
to create a sight picture we're starting
to go that way a little bit with
military rifle optics that just the very
beginnings are starting to use
camera optics rather than a simple lens
so that that's an interesting
extrapolation of
where things are going it looks enough
like a modern optical sight that you get
the idea that what it's supposed to be
but it's clearly very high-tech
okay so we've got a scene here of
effectively a sniper type weapon
clearly meant for longer range and is a
single shot
weapon sometimes we will find that if
you're increasing the
size of the of the projectile capability
of the ammunition
you end up having to sacrifice some of
that firepower it's reminiscent of some
of the very large anti-materiel rifles
where there's no magazine you literally
open the bolt put a single round in like
an old single shot breech loader from
the 19th century
close it up and fire it that's good for
gameplay balance because it can
only fire one shot and it's also
reflective of
as i say a reality yeah you could design
a gun that fires
whatever the heck that is 10 shots but
the gun that fires that would have to be
proportionately even bigger the magazine
would be huge and heavy
you don't want to be running and gunning
with that anyway
whether it's real life or in a game it
makes sense and it means that you're not
overpowered
[Music]
i'm fascinated by the wearable or the
prosthetic
weapons that we're seeing in this game i
haven't seen too much of it yet but
we've got the mantis blades here so
we're replacing the whole
arm or certainly the whole forearm with
not only a prosthetic hand but a
fold-out stabbing blade the idea of
weapons that are part of the body
is quite interesting we've got the um
certain indian
the punch daggers there's the qatar
effectively sword mounted on a gaunt
gauntlet so
it's coming out of your fist which were
real
practical weapons and are a logical
precursor to something like a
blade that's concealed in your arm
there is a an arm gun or a gun arm
depending on your point of view so we've
got here an arasaka
projectile launch system a missile
launcher in the palm of your hand more
or less literally
very good does look like it is like a
mini rocket any guided missile
system i think um realistically that
does make
a bit more sense than a trying to fit a
firearm into
an arm-sized device as long as you've
got a way to convey the mini missiles
into launch position then you're gonna
get i don't know how many shots you
could fit in your arm
but um yeah interesting very interesting
sorvi are you
willing yeah i'm in
so that was the weapons overview trailer
for cyberpunk 2077
thank you so much for watching and
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you